este es uno de los lugares más
emblemáticos de Argentina el glaciar
perito Moreno y sus 250 kilómetros
cuadrados de superficie más del doble
del tamaño de París cada día un promedio
de 2000 turistas viene a descubrir este
gigante de hielo subiendo cada vez que
tengamos una pendiente lo vamos a hacer
con pasos cortos sí algunos recorren su
superficie directamente con crampones Me
impactó
la grandeza la naturaleza como actúa y
nos pareció impresionante me sorprende
cada vez más la naturaleza los colores
Luis Cándido supervisa estas caminatas
sobre hielo desde hace 14 años se
realiza en la zona baja del glaciar casi
en el final del glaciar
es un área muy muy pequeña menos del 1%
porque glaciares es enorme
durante años el perito Moreno fue
considerado una excepción de la
naturaleza pues era uno de los pocos
glaciares en el mundo cuya superficie no
disminuía pero para Luis quien conoce
bien este paisaje este milagro argentino
ya no podría resistir al cambio
climático nosotros que somos guías y que
pasamos mucho tiempo en zonas acá del
borde del glaciar vemos que hay un
pequeño
achicamiento del glaciar Pero bueno ese
incomparable con otros glaciares de la
zona que
con pequeñas diferencias de latitud se
han achicado muchísimo la Patagonia es
actualmente la región del mundo con el
deshielo más rápido y las demás
provincias argentinas tampoco se salvan
ante esta emergencia el gobierno lo
encomendó a un equipo de científicos la
tarea de hacerles un seguimiento a estos
gigantes de hielo nos falta una horita
para llegar al glaciar desde que
empezamos a medir en el 2017 ya lleva
500 metros de retroceso Así que se va a
estirar un poquito más dos veces al año
el investigador pierpité y su equipo van
al glaciar azufre en el oeste de
Argentina para tomar muestras acá lo que
vamos a hacer es medir la cantidad de
nieve que hay en este punto y para eso
vamos a usar esta Sonda de inoxidable
que hacemos dos mediciones al año una
vez al final del Invierno que es lo que
estamos haciendo ahora en para ver
Cuánta nieve de toda la que cayó en el
invierno queda arriba del glaciar y
después vamos a volver al final del
verano Y ahí vamos a hacer la cuenta
Cuánto se derritió podemos saber si el
gaseo está perdiendo hielo y nieve y a
qué taza lo está perdiendo año tras año
estos científicos llegan a la misma
conclusión todos los glaciares que
supervisan están perdiendo superficie lo
cual tiene graves consecuencias en los
glaciares fundamentalmente son agua en
estado Sólido y se va liberando en los
ríos en los ecosistemas Durante los
periodos secos tanto en la estación seca
pero también en años secos en particular
cuando por razones el cambio climático
los glaciares empiezan a retroceder va a
ser que tenemos menos agua y que la
estación seca sea cada vez más larga
entonces la vegetación tiene menos
tiempo para crecer con menos agua
disponible Por ende cuando los glaciares
disminuyen a causa del cambio climático
nuestra capacidad para contrarrestar los
efectos de las sequía se ve afectada
algunas regiones de Argentina dependen
completamente de estos como la desértica
provincia de Mendoza que paradójicamente
tiene el mayor número de empresas
agrícolas el país tenemos una boca de
salida y en esa boca de salida la finca
están distribuidas por por cuarteles el
agua empieza a llegar a los pies de la
planta aquí Facundo chalamán cultiva
diez hectáreas de Olivos en Mendoza no
llueve o sea la única forma que hay de
que se vaya acumulando el agua en esos
acuíferos es a través de la nieve que
cae en la Cordillera de los Andes que ya
de unos 20 años venimos con los
problemas graves de disminución de
reservas de glaciares hay meses que no
sacar el agua entonces eso nos obliga a
que tengamos que estar bajando las
bombas Aunque el cambio climático es
difícil de controlar a Escala Nacional
Argentina decidió legislar para proteger
de forma concreta sus glaciares y la
calidad del agua en 2010 el país aprobó
una ley única en el mundo que prohíbe
toda explotación especialmente minera
alrededor de los glaciares pero para que
la ley pudiera aplicarse Primero era
necesario ser un inventario de todos los
glaciares del país este trabajo Fue
llevado a cabo por investigadores el
Instituto argentino de nepología la base
de nuestro trabajo de inventario son las
imágenes satelitales sobre las imágenes
satelitales nosotros ya sea
automáticamente o pudimos identificar
estos glaciares sino que también fuimos
al campo a donde fuimos a corroborar que
lo que nosotros estábamos haciendo que
nuestro trabajo coincidía con la
realidad después de más de siete años de
trabajo Se contabilizaron 16.000
glaciares ahora que ya está de
inventariados pueden ser protegidos por
la ley para satisfacción de las
organizaciones medioambientales la ley
de glaciares es una de las mejores leyes
ambientales que tenemos en Argentina
porque protege a los glaciares de manera
integral ya que no solamente protege la
masa de hielo per se sino también toda
el área alrededor que se llama el área
periglaciar sin el cual el glaciar no
puede existir el que se pudieron frenar
más de 44 proyectos mineros que estaban
en etapas de exploración en la zona de
la Cordillera en 2020 tras las quejas de
las grandes empresas mineras la Corte
Suprema de Argentina declaró
constitucional la ley de protección de
glaciares a pesar de los esfuerzos
realizados por el país estos gigantes de
hielo siguen estando en peligro de
desaparición según la UNESCO un tercio
de los glaciares declarados patrimonio
mundial están condenados a desaparecer
en los próximos 30 años